all right ted take a look at this video  from our aviator drone you can see the  haze right there just completely clouded  the skies today and you know it really  is unfortunate because i'm i'm one of  the ones that is really enjoying this  cooler temperature but of course we have  so many folks out there with allergies  and obviously that can't be good right  yeah anyway with asthma this is just one  of those days you just want to stay  inside do your exercising inside we gave  you fair warning about this yesterday  right this was gonna happen so of course  christian we're keeping our eye on that  haze right now because it's still out  there maybe not as dense as this morning  where i woke up and i was like i know i  didn't call for clouds today because you  couldn't really see the sunshine but i  knew it was the smoky haze that moved  its way in